orientale on m'a dit ce soir on a la
chance je voulais dit de recevoir une
rico macias donc les chroniqueurs ont
envie de rendre hommage à tout ce qui
est orientale on va commencer avec le
plus grand bien sûr un deuxième combat
seas est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
jean michel lemaire c'est khaled
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aïcha oui donc je vais pas aux tirs et
un mec qui vient d'être élu maire on va
passer une chanteuse qui a explosé grâce
au film la vérité si je mens alors ça
aussi c'est une cata enfin vous pourrez
bientôt alabina c'est quoi si je te
ramène
l'eau
on va passer un trio qui a marqué
l'histoire du rail voici les airs de 3,7
il
[Musique]
elle est ouvert jusqu'à quelle heure
vous mes profs c'est quoi cette danse
orientale on m'a dit il fait voir
et pour finir un chanteur que j'adore et
là est avec nous ce soir c'est le petit
prince du raï faudel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]